essa mãe do rico quando tem confusão na
escola você pode prestar atenção que a
mãe nunca sabe o que que estava
acontecendo que a mãe do rico ela pensa
que o filho é um anjo isso que eu acho
interessante olha Dona no Loures é
impossível tá o meu filho tá meu filho
Jared Jared impossível ele colocar a
cola no corr irmão da escada porque meu
filho não é de fazer essas coisas lá em
casa ninguém ensina a mãe do pobre não a
mãe do Pobre quando chama ela na escola
ela já vai sabendo que ela conhece a
peça que ela tem em casa ela no briga
com professor não quando a gente chega
na diretoria fala que foi mãe el olha
pra gente fala assim bonito bonito Vânia
não vai acontecer mais isso se voltar
pra escola porque quando chegar em casa
gleon não gleon volte fica aqui você vai
escutar ela conhece já isso se for
chamado na diretoria agora se for briga
na escola brigou com coleguinha
coleguinha é o que a mãe acha o que as
professoras acham que são coleguinha mas
são tudos uns capetinhas tem nemum
coleguinha ali a mãe do rico Ela briga
pelo filho assim com unhas e dentro
porque para ela o filho dela é um anjo a
maior diferença é essa quando tem dois
meninos brigando na escola ela acho que
sempre foi outro menino que procurou
conversa com ele procurou em tica